a little while back
i misinterpreted something that youtube
had put
as a suggestion about how we might reach
fans and subscribers as a new future
that they had rolled
out so as you can see here i wrote
trying out this new suggested feature in
youtube
caption contest youtube was just telling
us you should run
caption contests so i did that with this
image from one of my intro to philosophy
classes
at marist college back in about 2011
and there were a number of interesting
captions for it
and queries and questions and comments
so two that came up right away lenny
penny wrote i want to know the context
for this picture
and jeffrey bailey asked where was this
at
so of course the answer to that is it
was at marist college
in poughkeepsie new york i had recently
moved up there in 2011 leaving my
position
as an assistant professor up for early
tenure and promotion
i moved up to the hudson valley to be
with my at that point
uh fiance now now wife andy
and i began teaching as an adjunct at
marist college
where i got to teach intro to philosophy
and ethics classes and
so you know aristotle was one of the
people i wanted to teach in intro to
philosophy and we did the metaphysics
book one
so that talks about different causes and
you notice that
on the screen behind me or rather the
chalkboard behind me there is a diagram
about
the different four causes efficient
final formal and material and i was
using props that day
to demonstrate it so i brought in my
dad's old banjo been my banjo for
really decades now and i thought this
would be a useful
way to convey things and students really
responded to it they always love when
you bring in
any sort of you know unusual things and
a banjo is probably better for that than
a guitar i also brought in a recorder
that day as well and i think i might
have used a sandwich as another example
so that's what was going on you can see
me here
basically walking them through things
about the banjo and its causality using
aristotle's ideas so i said
caption this and people did the first
three captions were really about
you might say jokey things that have to
do with with
music so the first one the banjo at the
gates of dawn
not really about banjos as such that's a
reference to
pink floyd's piper at the gates of dawn
record but i thought that was kind of
funny
then somebody had something that was
specifically about banjo's
foggy aristotelian breakdown i think
it's foggy mountain breakdown it's kind
of an old-timey banjo
song and then we have so is reading
foucault
down on the bayou foucault of course is
a french philosopher and historian
and banjos are associated with uh among
other things
um louisiana and so that that makes a
bit of sense
then there were some other good comments
as well
uh probably only fellow banjo players
will get this one but how about
philosophizing with a
claw hammer so you know who is the
philosopher with the hammer that would
be friedrich nietzsche
and claw hammer is a particular style of
playing with the banjo that i actually
do myself use from time to time
the next one i kind of got a kick out of
this one i can just play this banjo
until you're all ready to settle down
and pay attention i can play it all day
your choice there's this is a bit of a
side note but there's always this
notion that like banjo playing is
somehow
you know like bagpipes it's not for
everybody and
maybe it would be a punishment to play
it in a class or
something like that the next one uh
dialectic banjos aristotelian
deliverance from andoxa they managed to
really pack a lot of
ideas into that one so instead of
dueling banjos
dialectic banjos okay makes sense with
aristotle since he does talk about
the dialectic uh process
and dialectics involve and doxa these
are
common ideas about things and of course
you know deliverance is the movie
where dueling banjos is a a major part
of the soundtrack
the next one pov you try to get into
philosophy by reading
kant and end up losing your mind i
thought that was kind of funny it
doesn't really have much to do with the
banjo first say
but i thought that uh yeah you know
reading kant you you could lose your
mind and maybe then you bring a banjo to
class
uh the next one wittgenstein ending
philosophy
circa 1921
colorized the idea would be that very
improbable that that wittgenstein would
do so with the banjo which
was actually an instrument used in bands
at that time but
you know i don't know that wittgenstein
had any connections to
to music per se but i might be wrong
about that
and then the last two are particularly
good so i really like this one yeah
that's how i beat the devil in a banjo
contest when he came up here and tried
to give
get me to give up my book collection so
you know there's the
old story about the devil going down to
georgia now that has to do with a fiddle
not a banjo but it's still sort of a you
know
country instrument and uh you know
beating the devil in a banjo contest i
guess would be quite a thing to do
and last and definitely not least we
have
from virginia charlotte a little poem
uh someday we'll find it the metaphysics
four causes the matter form
agent and end all of its un under its
spell we know
aristotle is magic
and uh i imagine this is supposed to be
a song set to music so
kind of a nice response there as well so
those are
the best of the responses that i got
from this particular caption contest i
thought i would
share the results of my
mistake with you and some of you might
get a
kick out of it you know i do i'll put a
link
below to a video where i'm actually
discussing this banjo in question you
can click
see more and also put a link to the
aristotle lecture
as such from this this particular class
so you can click on that as well but
i'll do more of these caption contests
in the future if people are
interested in them i'll find some other
good images maybe from classes or maybe
from some
other things and we'll we'll see what
people come up with and then i'll make
some
videos about them
you